[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde nous allons vous parler de la
situation du logement en France la bombe
socioéconomique et environnementale du
logement incontestablement il y a une
crise du logement en France et aussi
affirmativement il n'y a pas de
véritable politique du logement ce
constat posé une kirielle de problèmes
sociaux économiques fonciers
administratif environnementaux et
politiques viennent scander ce qui
constitue une bombe à fragmentation
humaine et sociale qui touche l'ensemble
de la population excepté la frange la
plus aisée qui dispose de revenus
importants cette crise vient pénaliser
considérablement les plus pauvres à
savoir d'après le dernier rapport de la
Fondation Abé pierre concernant la
France en
2022 4 millions de personnes mal logées
voire sous-logé et aussi grave d' 12
millions de personnes fragilisées à des
degrés divers pour se trouver un toit
subvenir aux dépenses quotidiennes en ce
qui concerne le logement étudiant il
manquerait 250000 logements à l'instar
de ce qui s'est produit avec la révolte
des gilets jaunes et de l'augmentation
du prix du diesel comme facteur
déclenchant c'est l'augmentation ou ça
serait l'augmentation des taux d'intérêt
au
par les banques sur les crédits
immobiliers qui a mis en exerg cette
crise du logement en France au point de
provoquer ce cri du cœur de Geoffroy rou
bieux ancien président du mdeef la
France va au- devant d'une catastrophe
dans le domaine du logement nous allons
en parler avec mes invités que je vous
présente Emmanuel Kos vous êtes
président de l'Union sociale pour
l'habitat vous êtes ancienne ministre du
logement et de l'habitat durable Pascal
Lagrue vous êtes secrétaire confédéral
pour le développement et le logement à
force Ouvrière Michel Cantal Dupart vous
êtes architecte urbaniste professeur
honoraire au knnam Julien Damont vous
êtes sociologue enseignant à sciencesp
Paris et
AHC
[Musique]
alors de la Fondation Abbé Pierre auedev
vous avez pu le voir les mises en garde
apostrophe les pouvoirs publics sur la
crise du logement certes les problèmes
qui touchent les plus pauvres ne sont
pas de même gravité que ce qui concerne
le reste de la population mais on peut
dire qu'elle est également touchée nous
allons entrer dans le détails au fil de
la discussion mais pour commencer à
votre avis Emmanuel k quel sont les
mesures d'urgence que vous préconisez
pour éviter cette catastrophe dont parle
geoffroid rou bieux vous voyez la
première mesure CEN est pas une c'est
simplement d'admettre ce que vous venez
de dire dire que vous avez fait le
constat que c'est une crise en devenir
mais à mon avis elle est déjà là qui a
un risque d'éclatement social c'est
partagé par des mouvements associatifs
comme par le MDEF les partenaires
sociaux en général et pourtant le
Président de la République
depuis 7 ans quand il parle de logement
ce n'est jamais pour parler de ça c'est
soit pour dire le logement ça coûte trop
cher le logement ça marche pas mais
jamais pour dire il y a une crise
sociale notre société va mal les
Français sont mal logés il faut que je
trouve des moyens d'améliorer ça
mobilisons-nous tous ensemble et en fait
c'est ça la première mesure c'est en
fait un point de vue politique et après
je pourrais vous décrire des tas de
mesures mais ce qui nous manque le plus
aujourd'hui c'est ce fossé entre un
constat qui est en plus partagé par de
plus en plus d'acteurs C cris d'alerte
que nous poussons et en face une non
réponse mais ils ont quand même essayé
avec le Conseil national de la
refondation et typiquement c'est très
intéressant le président lance le
Conseil national de la refondation les
partenaires sociaux exigent car ce
n'était pas prévu au début une réunion
spécifique sur le logement elle est
convoquée on on y travaille tous il y a
300 acteurs différents qui qui
participent il y a Desf on produit des
tas de trucs comme on sait faire et y
compris il y a un bouger des uns et des
autres parce qu'on se dit mais comment
on fait là pour vraiment répondre à
l'urgence le résultat c'était au mois de
juin une réunion où en fait on nous a
dit c'était très bien votre travail mais
en fait on a rien à vous proposer
çaétait une une douche froide très forte
et depuis donc ça c'était en juin et
depuis objectivement il ne s'est rien
passé donc je je voyez après je pourrais
vous décliner des mesures aider le
logement social aider l'accession à la
propriété libérer les fonciers pour
qu'il soi moins cher réguler les marchés
parce qu'il y a tous ces sujetsl qui se
posent mais au-delà de ça il y a une
question euh principale qui est vraiment
la prise en compte de cette cette
priorité de cette urgence dans la
période actuelle si vous aviez une
mesure à proposer une mesure à proposer
on passera dans le détail de cette ce
cette absence de politique Pascal Lagrue
ce serait quoi moi dans les dans les
mesures qu'on aurait à proposer c'est
que on fasse en
sorte que tous les acteurs du logement
je je dis bien tous les acteurs que ce
soit ceux qui sont dans le parétarisme
ceux qui sont on va dire au sein de
l'USA au sens large euh fassent en sorte
d'arrêter de jouer au ping-pong avec les
finances qui financent justement ce
logement et en particulier le logement
social pour justement on puisse faire en
sorte de répondre à la problématique
emploi logement c'est ça qui a derrière
cette crise du logement si vous voulez
on parlera un petit peu plus après de de
de des enjeux sur les emplois
on rentrera dans le détail mais
aujourd'hui il y a une chose qui est
quand même c'est un constat majeur avec
en gros le coût d'une construction
individuelle maison qui augmente de plus
de 25 % en 2 ans et 40 % de production
de logement en moins depuis 2 ans et
bien ça veut dire qu'on est vraiment en
en état de récession sur le logement
donc il faut vraiment que les les fonds
qui sont attribués au logement le Soi
vraiment et et qu'on arrête de jouer au
jeu à chal souris en disant ça c'est mon
budget ça c'est pas mon budget et cetera
et vous quelle mesure vous préconiserz
alors j'attrape la baguette magique et
je dirais que il faut davantage
décentraliser cette politique du
logement ça ne répond pas immédiatement
au problème des gens mais ça serait une
simplification à mon avis nécessaire et
possible de tout cet attiraage de
politique assez compliqué il a
décentralisé ça veut pas dire que l'État
n'aurait pas son mot à dire notamment
dans la péréquation des financements
mais je souhaiterais qu'il y ait
davantage de responsabilités qui soit
confié alors à quelle échelle
précisément disons les métropoles ou les
intercommunalités merci Michel Cantal
Dupart une mesure pour vous pour
débloquer la la situation une mesure
mais après on rentrera dans le détail on
a connu des problèmes de crise c'est pas
nouveau on s'est donné des
ambition sur une succession de plan qui
n'était pas raisonnable je prends un
exemple sur le grand en Paris il était
dit il faut construire 70000 logements
par an bon c'est ça été dit ça a été mis
dans la loi on l'a même fait hein oui
mais c'est oui donc c'est ah oui mais on
l'a fait plusieurs années B oui mais bon
mais tu as raison on l'a fait alors il
faut il faut enfin la décentralisation
c'est c'est bon moi je pense j'ai connu
le passage de l'aide à la pierre à
l'aide à la
personne je pense qu'il faudrait
revisiter et garder l'air de la personne
parce que c'est quand même pas mal mais
revenir à une certaine aide à la pierre
je me souviens très bien à l'époque les
organismes sociaux étaient montés au
créneau en disant euh on court à la
catastrophe parce que bon on y est 50
ans après quand même mais donc je pense
que c'est une mesure à à piocher à voir
et puis et puis euh pour répondre à aux
problèmes de crédit les gens travaillent
de façon individuelle
alors ça peut être le relais de
collectivité territoriale mais surtout
il y a une chose qui a qu'on connaît mal
mais qui est dans la loi aussi c'est
l'habitat participatif et qui permet un
groupement de gens un peu comme
autrefois les castors mais plus moderne
mais un groupement de gens de pouvoir et
parce qu'il un groupement ils ont
peut-être une accession au au crédit
peut-être je ne suis pas banquier
ép
discter c'était à quelle époque les
castors après la guerre la
reconstruction laonstruction la
reconstruction c'est des gens qui
avaient qui qui voulaient faire c'était
pas des sinistrés c'était pas des
c'était des gens qui voulaient faire de
l'accession à la propriété et qui
ensemble construisaient leur maison
ensemble c'està-dire que il y avait tous
les corps de métiers ça ça a eu un
succès formidable moi je alors Emmanuel
vous avez été ministre ouis qu'est-ce
que vous prenez
ou vous
pronneriez pour à l'état pour corriger
le tir d'un point de vue institutionnel
est-ce que c'est un minist un N un
ministère du Logement doté de crédit
exceptionnel est-ce que c'est est-ce que
c'est une délégation auprès du Premier
ministre sur le plan de l'état non mais
simplement déjà un ministre de plein
exercice un ministre qui ne soit pas
délégué ou qui ne soit pas secrétaire
d'État monsieur Béchu non monsieur
vergrit est ministre du Logement délégué
de monsur auprès de Monsieur béchuè mais
monsieur Béchu est ministre du Logement
également ou il est ministre du Logement
de l'écologie de la ruralité de la
biodiversité et j'en oublie des
transports et d'autres donc vous prenez
un ministre du Logement et je vais vous
dire pourquoi moi j'ai eu cette chance
d'être ministre de plein exercice du
logement et donc d'être à la table du
Conseil des ministres toutes les
semaines quels que soient les sujets
toutes les semaines puisque j'étais dans
le le le conseil le plus restreint et
donc aussi de pouvoir porter mes sujets
toutes les semaines et avec le Premier
ministre et avec le président de la
République et ça aide aussi parce que de
fait ça vous donne un rang de discussion
avec l'ensemble des ministères qui est
très important vous savez c'est des
choses que vous allez trouver un peu
futille mais même les rangs
protocolaires ils ont de l'importance
dans ces questions-là quand vous êtes un
ministre de plein exercice quand vous
allez discuter avec le ministre de
l'économie et des finances ou celui des
comptes publics de votre budget bah
c'est différent oui mais madame COS si
ça va mal aujourd'hui c'est que ça
allait mal avant alors est-ce que ça ce
qui a été fait avant n'était pas bien
non
plus parce que quand une catastrophe
arrive c'est qu'il y a une continuité
dans l'échec bah là en effet il y a une
continuité depuis 2017 ça c'est très
clair mais moi et avant alors vous
pensez cement non enfin en tout cas
quand moi je suis partie de mon
ministère la construction était pas en
berne elle était fortement en hausse on
produisait 125000 logements sociaux par
an et pas 80000 donc c'est des choix qui
ont été faits mais on oublie un peu les
choses qui sont passées parce que
évidemment que rien n'est parfait fait
il y a pas d'un un côté blanc ou noir la
la difficulté à se loger elle est
ancienne elle a amené des politiques
comme l'encadrement des loyers comme la
décotte des fonciers donc évidemment qui
on a quand même en France une difficulté
sur ce sujet-là depuis longtemps là ce
qui change c'est qu'elle s'aggrave elle
s'aggrave de manière très vite mais je
dois rappeler ce qui s'est passé en 2017
dans les premiers mois d'arrivée
d'Emmanuel Macron au pouvoir et
notamment d'Édouard Philippe dès juillet
2017 on décide quoi de réduire le budget
des aide à la pierre pour le logement
social pour réduire l'objectif de
production de l'année même de logements
sociaux pour les passer de 125000 à
110000 on enlève 5 € d'APL donc de
l'aide personnelle à chaque personne qui
l'a sur son sur ce qu'elle recevait donc
y compris des personnes qui vivaient
avec un minimum de 600 € on leur
enlevéit 5 € de de prestation sociale ça
a commencé comme ça et surtout depuis
2018 c'est la politique du logement dans
sa globalité et je ne remets pas en
cause tout mais en tout cas la politique
du logement dans sa dans sa totalité a
contribué à faire des économies
budgétaires énormes oui mais tout n'est
pas que la faute du pouvoir prenons par
exemple d'un point de vue foncier
regardez d'un point de vue foncier juste
la moi terminer sur l'économie moi moi
en tant que bailleur social depuis 2018
le les bailleurs sociaux contribuent à
hauteur de 1 milliard 3 au budget de
l'État on nous prend nos loyer pour
aller au budget de l'État vous
connaissez un autre secteur qui fait ça
on loge les gens les plus pauvres de
France et on nous demande de contribuer
au budget de l'État ça s'appelle un
prélèvement à la source mais je suis
désolé ça c'est ça aujourd'hui on en
paye on en paye le prix c'està 6 ans
plus tard et ben la Caisse des dépôts
des consignations vient de dire que nous
n'avions plus la capacité de produire
suffisamment de logement écoutez prenons
le cas le côté foncier monsieur Damont
les élus prennent prétexte de la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation
concernant la résidence principale pour
limiter les permis de
construire il y a aussi le contexte
environnemental qui limite
l'artificialisation net des sols est-ce
qu'il y a pas quelque chose à changer
aussi dans ce domaine foncier dans ce
domaine foncier ce qu'il faut c'est
limiter la consommation de foncier dans
un français plus simple il faut l'étaler
enfin il faut limiter l'étalement urbain
et il faut d'un point de vue écologique
contribuer à une densification heureuse
sont des termes que les urbanistes
comprennent pour tout le monde ça
signifie que plutôt que de se concentrer
comme on le fait beaucoup sur la
construction neuve qui reste nécessaire
je pense que la voie d'avenir à laquelle
contribuent les différents opérateurs de
la politique du logement c'est la
rénovation la rénovation c'est pas
prendre une vieille grange pour en faire
une super résidence c'est pas prendre un
vieux bâtiment osmanien pour le rendre
plus joli c'est prendre une grande
partie de notre territoire qui est déjà
urbanisé et en faire des villes avec de
l'habitat de qualité pour tous donc
moins de consommation de foncier et
davantage d'utilisation foncier qui est
déjà artificialisé alors Michel Cantal
DUP vous avez été en contact avec le
foncier à l'époque où vous vous occupz
oui mais à l'époque quand vous aviez à
gérer le projet banlieu 89 et cetera
est-ce que vous pensez pas que le
les les élus se défossent quelqueisends
un exemple des grands ensembles les
grands ensembles sont souvent des
quartiers sousdensifiés dans les villes
sousdensifié c'est des quartiers de
malvivre la seule façon de faire évoluer
ça c'est de construire et d'amener de la
qualité là où il y en a pas vous avez
des espaces publics euh je sais pas
comment euh vous avez plus d'arbres à La
Courneuve qu'il n'y en a dans le parc
Montsouris à à à superficie égale faut
savoir ça c'est mais c'est inud enfin
c'est invisible invisible donc il y a
vraiment repenser tout ça c'est le ça
devrait être le rôle de l'enrue mais
l'enue rue c'est c'est quoi l'en rue ah
oui l'Agence nationale de rénovation
urbaine c'est eux qui s'occupent des
quartiers d'ficile à laquel vous
participez très activement mais
là-dessus il y a une volonté des élus de
considérer ça comme des territoires hors
ville dans la dans leur tête he c'est on
parle de greffe mais ils font pas
grand-chose pour ça c'est hors ville et
c'est ben on va voir on démolit on
reconstruit mais il y a pas
d'intégration ré réel de ces quartiers
qui sont des potentiels formidables je
vois je vois le je prends un exemple
parce que c'est dans l'actualité pisevin
pisevin c'était moi je l'ai connu avec
anim Amim il y a deux quartiers il y a
pisevin et je sais plus comment
l'autre exactement et c'était deux
quartiers bon moi j'ai connu monsieur
Bousquet qui était maire je dis c'est
vraiment là le problème il faut unir ces
quartiers faut en faire au moment des
fer Nim il faut qu'il ait de la mai
enfin làdedans il faut que ça participe
de la feria parce qu'autrement les gens
ils viennent dans le centreville et puis
bon il faut qu'il ait qu'il se passe
quelque chose et je me souviens la DDE
avait été très active parce qu'ils
avaient des terrains au centre qu'ils
avaient mis à disposition c'est
formidable mais ça c'est arrêé là rien
n'a bougé aujourd'hui rien n'a bougé ou
pas beaucoup donc c'est on paye ça très
très très cher alors ça c'est une
solution
foncière facile pour reprendre ce que
Monsieur Damon disait faut réinvestir
les villes il faut regarder où il y a de
la place bon euh et puis et puis ben euh
vous avez ce que j'appelle les les
phénomènes d'auben c'est-à-dire C ces
villes qui sont pas plus dans la
banlieue mais un peu dans la campagne
qui sont aujourd'hui dévalorisé ou des
tas de jeunes ménages ça c'est autour de
toutes les villes je connais bien la
région de Bordeaux pour ça les gens sont
sont venus prendre des un habitat que
j'appelle
daben alors ils sont c'est un jeune
couple des enfants pour un peu que
l'école soit un peu performante tout est
très bien il ils ont deux bagnoles il
leur faut deux bagnoles pour travailler
dans la banlieue sud de Bordeaux par
exemple avec l'augmentation c'est
catastrophique l'augmentation de
l'essence de l'énergie et làdessus alors
Monsieur Macron avant d'être président
de la République avait une idée
formidable qui lui avait été soufflé par
Transdev que j'avais moi-même soufflé à
cet organisme Transdev organisme de
transport qui était les carart Macron
mais l'écart Macron c'était pour
justement euh faire faire des des
circulations des transports en commun là
où il n'existait plus au niveau des
départements or qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
fait tous ces tous ces ils ont profité
de l'obben eux et ils ont fait les
liaisons ils ont doublé la SNCF sur
c'est idiot c'est idiot il faut il faut
repenser un service de C de qui
permettent parce que on est sur un
territoire en France foncier vide
totalement vide des des tas de communes
sont vides elles sont monsieur Lagrue
qu'est-ce que vous préconisez sur sur ce
foncier à reverdir en quelque sorte sur
soncier moi je vais partager ce qui a
été dit puisque une référence a été
faite à l'enrue hein l'enrue c'est
important c'est bien évidemment il y a
le logement la production mais il faut
il faut aussi tout le parc à rénover et
euh où je vais partager le dernier
propos qui a été tenu fait c'est le fait
de dire qu'à un moment donné si on a une
forme de désertification c'est-à-dire
que il y a une capacité d'accueil qui
qui qui est complètement abandonné il
faut peut-être se poser la question à un
instant c'est et l'emploi dans tout ça
c'estàdire est-ce qu'on répond à ce que
le logement aille vers l'emploi et
est-ce qu'on fait en sorte que de
l'emploi fasse en sorte d'alimenter
aussi ce logement et ça ça passe par
quoi alors moi je vais je va je vais le
dire avec pardon vous voulez dire que le
logement en France n'est pas conçu comme
un élément de la question sociale
absolument il devrait l'être aussi comme
vous dites si bien de la question
sociale associé avec l'emploi pourquoi
parce que regardez quand des salariés
sur le plan privé décident de devenir
propriétaire ou quand des salariés lou
un logement que ce soit dans dans le
logement social ou pas bah ils font
quand même aujourd'hui leur
problématique d'être en proximité du
logement de l'emploi pardon emploi
logement il y a encore plus de sens pour
une raison aussi qui est économique je
vous le fais très court
mais l'ADN savez notre ADN nous il a
toujours été d'être dans dans le pouvoir
d'achat et aujourd'hui nous on dit
toujours régulièrement avoir un toit
c'est être bien chez soi mais pour être
bien chez soi chez soi on a un frigo à
remplir et le frigo si avec l'inflation
qu' a aujourd'hui vous le savez et que
les salaires n'augmentent pas tout
autant un des postes au plus on est près
de son logement au plus c'est un poste
sur lequel on peut économiser quand même
et donc dépenser Mo donc gagner du
pouvoir d'achat oui monsieur Damon il y
a une question que je voudrais élucider
avec vous on dit depuis un certain temps
que la hausse des taux d'intérêt est
invoquée comme le facteur déclenchant de
la crise du logement c'est vrai ou c'est
simplement pour se défausser sur
les disons la la déficience sociale la
crise du logement à mon avis elle est
quasi éternelle ceci dit celle dont on
parle aujourd'hui elle ne date pas de
l'augmentation des taux d'intérêt elle
est plus ancienne et elle tire des
racines dans le phénomène d'inflation
qui pèse se justifie économiquement par
les banques d'un point de vue purement
financier où c'est où les banques en
profitent saurait dire si les banques en
profitent vous avez des taux directeurs
de la Banque centrale qui font que les
banques elles-mêmes les banques
commerciales qui font nos crédits sont
obligés d'augmenter les les crédits on
peut résumer ça dans mes on pe encadrer
la chose là pour per mettre au moins
pour les catégories je sais pas ça
véritablement grand chose peut-être
faudrait-il regarder dans le détail pour
les plus défavoriser comme d'habitude ça
dépend de quoi on parle exactement alors
dire un mot là-dessus c'est considérer
de mon point de vue que la crise du
logement est d'abord une crise qui
aujourd'hui affecte les classe moyenne
c'est toujours facile de parler des
classe moyenne parce qu'on sait jamais
ce qu'elles sont exactement mais
admettons que ce soit les travailleurs
avec des revenus modè et là je suis
pleinement d'accord avec ce qui a été
évoqué on a une déconnexion même dans
nos politiques publiques en entre le
soutien à l'emploi et l'accès au
logement c'est assez préoccupant il y a
une des familles du logement social dont
c'est la fonction il y a même des
financements qu'on trouve sur nos fiches
de paye ça s'appelle le 1 % logement si
c'était simple ça serait encore 1 %
c'est un tout petit peu moins et je
pense ça devrait dans une logique de
sécurité sociale devenir une quasi
cotisation ouvrant des des droits alors
ça ouvre des possibilités mais pas des
droits mais je voudrais résumer la
situation de la crise du logement par
rapport à ce que vous évoquez sur les
taux d'intérêt elle est à mon sens P
aujourd'hui si je la caricature due à
deux phénomènes elle est due à
l'inflation et elle est due à la lutte
contre l'inflation elle est du à la
lutte en pardon à l'inflation parce que
les coûts de la construction augmentent
les gens ont de moins en moins de sous
pour pouvoir payer ce qui les fait bien
vivre dans leur logement c'est
l'inflation et du côté de la lutte
contre l'inflation il y a la politique
monétaire qui augmente les coûts du du
crédit donc vous voyez c'est à la fois
conséquence de cette inflation dont nous
pâtissons et conséquen de cet outil
important de la lutte contre l'in qu est
la politique monétaire alors écoutez je
voudrais revenir avec vous Emmanuel C
sur la question
environnementale la rénovation
environnementale globale est
insuffisante nous le
constatons il y a trop de passoir
thermiques nous le constatons des des
millions de résidences principales sont
affectés par ça mais nos voisins ne font
pas mieux les Allemands ont cédé sur
cette question vous le savez bien il y a
eu des problèmes entre les écologistes
et le SPD ils sont pas arrivés à
résoudre la question les Anglais avec le
le Premier ministre monsieur sunac a
fait savoir qu'on pouvait pas régler
simultanément les questions sociales et
environnemental est-ce que vous croyez
qu'on a les moyens les investissements
pour
permettre de ou supprimer un maximum de
passeoir thermique est-ce qu'il y a les
moyens de le faire est-ce qu'on a ce que
n' pas pu faire pas plus les Anglais que
les Allemands la première chose ça c'est
un point de vue totalement personnel
mais moi je ne crois pas qu'on règle les
questions environnementales si on règle
pas la question sociale et les deux sont
intimement liés et en particulier autour
du sujet de la rénovation des logements
alors vous citez des des pays qui en
effet ont renoncé à une exigence très
forte vous auriez pu aussi citer les
Pays-Bas qui ont eu une vision très
différente et y compris qu'on un secteur
bancaire dédié à ça et que c'est un
choix ancien c'est un choix ancien
et c'est vrai qu'en France en fait
depuis les années 2010 on tourne autour
de où où mettre la l'exigence le curseur
et derrièurs où mettre les financements
il a été fait le choix avec la loi
climat et résilience en en 2021 de de de
mettre un curseur très dur et qui
notamment avec une interdiction de
location à terme enfin c'est un peu plus
compliqué que ça mais aussi avec un
déploiement d'argent de d'aide de
subvention extrêmement élevé qui quand
même change un peu la par rapport au
passé ce que je veux dire par là c'est
qu'aujourd'hui quand on est propriétaire
y compris modeste on a beaucoup plus
d'aide aujourd'hui pour faire les
travaux que il y a quelques années y
compris quand j'étais ministre et j'ai
aucun mal à le reconnaître mais ça ne
suffira pas pour deux raisons d'une part
parce que se lancer dans des travaux
qu'en fait vous ne faites pas vraiment
pour vous les travaux d'amélioration de
votre bâti vous le faites par exemple si
vous avez plus de 70 ans vous avez du
mal à vous dire que c'est pour vous-même
c'est peut-être pour vos héritiers et et
peut-être il faut débourser au départ
une somme d'argent non négligeable vu
que les Allemands n'ont pas pu mettre
des pompes à chaleur système français le
système français d'IDE est quand même
beaucoup plus poussé vous avez compris
cette alliance entre les fonds de l'État
les fonds des collectivités locales des
subventions d'opérateurs une partie du
secteur HLM ce qu'on appelle je rentre
dans le jargon les sassicap quiamènne
des fonds supplémentaire on peut payer
quasiment l'ensemble de la dépense au
départ donc non non quand même je tiens
à le dire aujourd'hui c'est c'est on a
on a un un soutien financier qui n'a
rien à voir ça reste des travaux
compliqués et puis c'est la masse des
travaux et je pense qu'il y a deux
choses il y a le fait de le faire
individuellement de se lancer c'est
compliqué faut trouver le Conseil faut
trouver le les les les artisans et puis
aussi le le le le bon conseil pour le
faire et puis en masse je vous donne
juste un exemple et qui qui est pas
celui du financement mais pour le
logement social on a 5,6 millions de
logements selon la loi nous allons
devoir en réhabiliter environ 1 million
de en 12 ans c'est donc c'est un 5è donc
vous voyez c'est une augmentation du
rythme très fort et donc derrière ça
veut dire une économie qui se tourne
beaucoup plus vers la rénovation donc je
pense que c'est ça une des difficultés
mais néanmoins ça permet de dire une
chose c'est que aujourd'hui il suffit
pas d'offrir un toit à un ménage pour
qu'il aille bien encore faut-il qu'il
soit bien dans son logement ce ce dont
souffre beaucoup de ménag actuellement
beaucoup de famille et notamment avec le
coût de l'inflation le coût de l'énergie
c'est d'avoir froid dans leur logement
d' non mais avir donc a un coup de santé
enfin aujourd'hui c'est c'est renseigné
des personnes âgées qui vont mal d'un
point de vue de la santé parce qu'ell
elles n'ont pas d'eau chaude et elle ne
se chauffe pas donc il y a quand même
une urgence à ce qu'on résolve ce ce
sujet là qui est particulier par rapport
aux autres pays européens aussi je
permets de d'insister c'est que nous
avons beaucoup d'habitats qui existent
d'avant la Seconde Guerre mondiale et
d'avant la Première Guerre mondiale donc
vousmême vous pointez la difficulté ah
mais il y a une difficulté mais c'est
pas pour autant qu'on peut pas la
franchir après est-ce est-ce que le
calendrier imposé aujourd'hui est dur
oui il est est-ce queil va y avoir des
effets de seuil oui il est mais ce que
je veux dire par là c'est qu'on a quand
même des outils ce qui est compliqué
pour tout vous dire c'est que les
propriétaires sont acculés entre est-ce
que je fais les travaux est-ce que je
paye mon crédit est-ce que je paye ma
charge d'énergie qui a augmenté l'année
dernière très fortement les taxes
foncières enfin vous voyez je pense que
il y a beaucoup de ménages qui ont
acheté avec peu de revenus monsieur la
grrue je vais pas vous chausser de de
chaussures syndicales si je puis dire
mais vous êtes à force
Ouvrière la question d'une concurrence
entre question sociales et
environnemental se
pose sur l'inflation on considère que ça
pénalise pas de la même manière ceux qui
n'ont pas grand-chose dans leur poche et
ceux qui ont des hauts revenus pour le
logement la question n'est pas la même
entre ceux qui sont bien logés ceux qui
sont mal logés comment vous
réglez-vous cette mix cité entre
l'environnement et le social dans un
syndicat parce que c'est une question
qui se pose parce que tout le monde
n'est pas aussi comment dire mal doté
sur les questions essentielles comme le
logement et l'inflation ou d'autres
sujets on a toujours pensé que beaucoup
de choses doivent se régler par la
négociation c'est-à-dire que vouloir
faire de l'environnement un un ennemi de
l'emploi ou un ennemi du social c'est
une erreur oui mais ça c'est de
l'idéologie c'est de l'idéologie donc
nous on on pense que de toute façon on
peut le régler par négociation comment
vous allez comprendre au travers des
métiers justement qui alimentent toutes
les données environnementale qu'elle
soit dans l'industrie qu'elle soit dans
le logement et cetera il y a des
secteurs où on arrive à négocier prenez
par exemple je donne un exemple concret
quand on est en train de passer la
voiture électrique tout le monde le sait
quand on sait ce qu'il fallait comme
nombre de salariés pour construire un
moteur thermique et combien il en faut
aujourd'hui il y a quand même un énorme
écart donc un impact sur l'emploi un
certain nombre de négociations ont eu
lieu et il y a eu des engagements de
prix pour qu'il y ait un glissement et
une transformation sur le logement
j'allais vous dire que c'est un peu la
même chose aujourd'hui on a des outils
paritaires on a des outils paritaires on
a des discussions également qui doivent
se faire avec les tous les acteurs
sociaux sur qu'est-ce qu'on met comme
moyen comment on attribue les moyens
nous ce qu'on ce qu'on veut dire par là
si vous voulez ce qui est euh très
dommageable aujourd'hui c'est que si on
laisse la situation à l'état vous savez
ce qui va se passer c'est que il y a
plein d'emplois qui sont pas pourvu
aujourd'hui parce que les gens n'ont pas
le logement et il y a 150000 emplois là
c'est une donnée qui date de quelques
jours 150000 emplois qui sont menacés
directement par rapport à cette crise du
logement et je veux terminer par une
chose qui me tient vraiment à cœur c'est
que les anciennes crises du logement
qu'on
avait et la dernière vous savezyz on a
tous connu la crise des subpr hein
cétait une crise financière mais c'était
de la spéculation sur les logements qui
avait eu lieu je sais pas si on se
rappelle bien tous les mécanismes alors
aujourd'hui je pense que le problème
c'est qu'il faut qu'on qu'on se dise
autour autour de la table quel moyen on
va donner au logement pour que le
logement puisse au travers des mesures
alors on parlait de l'EN rue mais il y a
aussi les aides à la pierre je suis
assez d'accord avec ce qui a été dit
tout aussi ne peut pas tout
faire cette agence nationale pour la
rénovation urbaine il est régulateur
quand il régule voilà il régule quand
même les fonds et c'est pour ça enfin
qu' vous savez la régulation va toujours
avec la négociation quelqu'un qui veut
se mettre autour d'une table et bien on
y arrive et moi ce que dit Emmanuel C je
simplement vous en dire un tout petit
mot oui c'est quand on
pompe l'argent ou les bonnes gestions
des acteurs sociaux que nous sommes des
opérateurs
emuel parlait au niveau de l'USA je Mo
vous dire au niveau de l'action logement
où en siège on est des partenaires
sociaux qui qui siègeont dans Action
Logement on a les deux angles c'est la
la la bonne gestion de la structure pour
faire des logements sociaux le maximum
pour les salariés et en même temps faire
en sorte que les loyers soi un augmente
pas de manière exponentielle et cetera
et que et qu'en plus nous on fait de la
rénovation et cetera pour que le
logement coûte moins en énergie bah
quand vous avez un état qui à un moment
donné dit ah bah vous avez bien géré
vous avez super bien géré vous avez
tellement bien géré qu'on va vous faire
une ponction c'est la même chose que ce
qui s'est passé il y a quelques années
et j'étais déjà un engagé comme je peux
l'être aujourd'hui j'avais très mal vécu
je peux vous affirmer quelque chose qui
me tenait à cœur c'était la ponction et
c'était un autre gouvernement un autre
président sur les fonds sociaux de la
formation professionnelle 300 millions
d'euros on avait pompé parce que ça
avait été bien géré ça c'est quand même
[Musique]
insupportable on voit bien la citation
je vous est soumise de Jacques Herman ce
loger fait partie des besoins essentiels
comme travailler et
s'alimenter alors Michel quantal tu
parles aujourd'hui le cap
social on le voit pas parce que les
problèmes s'acumule l'inflation de 4 à
15 % attendez juste une baisse du
pouvoir d'achat l'accroissement des
populations précarisé des modes de vie
Solitair et cetera vous en tant
qu'architecte et
urbaniste vous pensez à cette à ce cap
social ou vous pensez au problème
particulier du logement ça veut dire
parce que si tout est dans tout comment
voulez-vous qu'on règle la question
écoutez je vais être très précis j'ai un
âge canonique 20 ans oui mais multiplié
par 4 et donc le le j'ai connu la fin de
la construction j'ai j'ai commencé à
travailler chez un architecte c'était la
fin de la reconstruction j'ai construit
des grands ensembles qui étaient le
l'espoir c'était vécu partout comme
l'espoir on va enfin pouvoir loger les
gens et moi je me rappelle très bien on
que les gens arrivaient et ils
allumaient ils éteignaient l'électricité
en disant c'est formidable il y a
électricité dans toutes les
pièceson oui les salles de on est
d'accord on est d'accord bon qu'est-ce
qui a changé alors d'abord la demande en
logement on a à cette époque là le
logement céit une famille aujourd'hui un
logement c'est une famille éclaté c'est
souvent trop souvent de logement en
principe à
proximité vous avez commencer en parlant
de des de la demande des de
la des logements
étudiants vous avez un truc qui
s'appelle parcours Sud qui éclate
aujourd'hui les étudiants dans toute la
France moi je vois mes petits enfants il
ils pourraient faire des études pr loger
chez leurs parents le temps des études
comme ça a été mon cas un peu et notre
cas à tous peut-être mais ils sont l'un
est à Bayon l'autre à à roubet enfin
c'est ils sont éclatés dans toute la
France donc il faut trouver des
logements oui mais à 50 ans les étudiant
les étudiants aussi habiti dans des
chambre de bonne ils avaient pas des
studios en ville oui enfin ils
habitaient beaucoup habitaient dans ma
génération c'est c'était des gens aisés
faut savoir aussi il y a la
démocratisation mais c'était des gens
aisés qui habitai ça ça pas de gros moi
je vois bien mais mes copains de moi
j'ai moi j'habita une pule mais mes
copains ils étaient chez leurs parents
tout c'était tout tout était bien ça ça
a changé c'est une évolution c'est une
demande nouvelle là-dessus on a un
gouvernement qui ne sait pas répondre à
ça parce qu'il a une réponse bien sûr
que le un ministre du Logement est très
important et un ministre du Logement qui
prend ça en tant que tel mais la réponse
à une politique du logement c'est
interministériel je prends un exemple
j'ai pris l'exemple de pisevin qu'est-ce
qui se passe pisevin qui arrive là le
ministre de l'Intérieur en disant bougez
pas vous allez
plaque allez 20 20 gendarmes mais c'est
pas une réponse la vraie réponse c'est
globaliser
autour le ministre du Logement parce que
ça concerne le logement le ministre de
l'éducation nationale parce que ça
concerne le ministre l'éducation
nationale et cetera et et c'est donc un
TER ministériel il devait y aller avec
trois qure gus B forcément la première
ministre et on parlait l'autre on parle
tout à l'heure de des des collectivités
territoriales les collectivités
territoriales moi je sais très bien jeen
connais plein elles veulent pas agandir
leur leurs communes parce que agrandir
leurs commune ça veut dire agrandir
l'école c'est pour eux c'est leur
financementcole communal ils disent ça
va un lotissement non non tant d'enfants
non on peut plus voilà et il y a un
ralentissement donc ça c'est pris en
compte par qui qui vient aider à cela
alors je parle pas des transports des
gens qui vont travailler euh on vente le
covoiturage c'est en train de marcher
moi j'y croyais pas ça marche ça marche
je vois bien moi tous les matins là près
de mes échangeurs les gens ils arrivent
ils C voiture c'est il y a une certaine
coordination des choses mais c'est quand
même des pansements sur des jambes de
bois quoi il y a pas de pensée réelle
d'un développement de ces quartiers ex
très excentrés et quand je parlais alors
tout le monde dit mais le télétravail
parce que c'est mais le télétravail les
gens vont dans des communes équipées
avec de c'est de l'emploi qui va là où
il y a de l'emploi où il y a du commerce
on descend on peut acheter ses
cigarettes et sa baguette de pain à
moins de 400 m aujourd'hui il y a des
tas de villes qui sont vides et que le
télétravail ne touche pas parce que pour
acheter une baguette de pain il faut
faire 7 voir 14 km le pouvoir n'est pas
responsable de la gentrification des
villes à savoir que il y a des
déplacements de population la sociologie
urbaine ne dépend pas elle est elle est
mondialisée aussi non qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez monsieur dam on est je ne sais
pas moi compar nous on est dans une
république hein chaque citoyen a un
pouvoir où qu'il soit il y a pas de mec
de la Creuse qui est moins bien que le
mec qui habite le valde Marne voilà
c'est pas vrai et ça on est on na pas
encore totalement compris ça monsieur
Damon sur une question précise alors
estce qu'il faut quand même les
problèmes de location est-ce qu' ces
problèmes là sont liés au aux abus
d'Airbnb par exemple alors on peut
répondre oui comme ça je laisse du temps
aux autres ceci dit ça n'est pas la
seule raisons j'en vois d'autres j'en
vois une assez fondamentale de
spécificité française c'est que les
investisseurs institutionnels on peut
les mettre du côté public mais égal
éement du côté privé les assureurs les
banques se sont désengagés du marché
locatif les principaux propriétaires
aujourd'hui je parle pas du logement
social mais du locatif privé ce sont des
individus certains sont très riches très
méchants ils ont du logement et cetera
d'autres bah ont un ou deux studioos ont
du mal à mettre ça sur le marché donc un
des sujets c'est comment faire pour
faire revenir ces investisseurs
institutionnels pour qu'il a davantage
de logement locatif troième élément
peut-être plus plus controversé moi je
suis pas un in iitionnel du contrôle des
loyers je dis ça de manière diplomatique
ça peut avoir ses vertus immédiates ça
peut avoir ses effets pervers qui
poussent une partie justement de ces
investisseur à se retirer du marché
locatif donc oui airbnbnco ça a son
impact vraiment mais vous le voyez c'est
pas du tout le seul
problème Madame K est-ce que vous
pourriez nous dire nous donner quelques
chiffr puisquon entend dire qu'il manque
4 millions de logements il en manque de
de 5000 ou 250000 pour les étudiants il
y a pas assez de
location si vous faisiez un tableau
clair il manque combien de logement en
France et voilà qu'on sache un petit peu
parce que vous vous travaillez dans cet
organisme oui mais vous vous touchez là
une des questions que d'ailleurs on va
discuter au Congrès HLM oui mais
justement non mais c'est il y a deux
choses manqueil il y a je pense deux
choses à distinguer besoin au logement
c'est-à-dire que vous l'avez très bien
décrit dans votre introduction tout le
monde ne souffre pas d'une difficulté de
logement justement donc le besoin au
logement ça on arrive à le dire quand
même on le voit avec les demandeurs HLM
il y a 1,7 million de ménages j'ai bien
dit des ménages et pas des personnes 1,7
millions de ménages qui attendent un
logement social ça veut dire qu'elles
ont du mal à se loger ailleurs au en
location ou en location en location donc
vous dites 1 1,7 million de ménages qui
attendent un logement àoué dans le
logement HLM et dans dans ces ménages là
je vous le dis quand même plus de 60 %
sont sous les seuils de pauvreté et la
moitié est actif et je pense très
important de le redire c'est que qui a
du mal aujourd'hui à se loger par
rapport au prix des marchés c'est en
fait un actif qui gagne autour du SMIC
qui est à temps partiel ou à temps plein
et qui est en fait sous le seuil de
pauvreté et vous voyez la grande
différence a que peut-être il y a 50 ou
60 ans où il y avait aussi des problèmes
de mallogement c'est qu'aujourd'hui on n
pas de réponse à apporter de manière
massive
au travailleurs à temps plein qui gagne
le SMIC pour se loger correctement moins
mes grand-parents location mais même
l'accession moi je al pour l'accession
qu'est-ce qui manque l'accession je
pense que c'est c'est bien plus
compliqué et c'est pour ça je vais pas
vous donner un chiffre on a parlé
pendant très longtemps et c'est un
chiffre en fait qui revient dans des
études y compris récentes qui sont
travaillé actuellement d'un besoin en
production ça veut pas dire que c'est du
neuf hein mais d'arriver sur le marché
globalement de 500000 logements que ça
soit du locatif ou de l'acession
construire à construire ou à je
dirais je par an je dirais produire
500000 logements oui je dirais produire
c'est pas que du neuf attention je parle
pas de 500000 logements neuf c'est produ
c'est du neuf et de la rovation et
l'acquisition amélioration de logement
comme il y en a beaucoup ailleurs dans
beaucoup dans beaucoup de villes parce
qu'on fait beaucoup de de ça mais aussi
pourquoi vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
on est dans un univers
mondialisé le besoin au logement et le
problème de logement je parle pas que
d'Airbnb sont aussi liés à la très forte
attractivité de la France comme première
destination touristique donc globalement
nous souffrons de d'un manque de lit
hôteliier de résidence hôtelière de
d'accueillir tous ces gens ces millions
de personnes enfin nous sommes la
première destination mondiale toutes ces
personnes qui venaient quand même
beaucoup moins il y a plusieurs
décennies elles se logent quelque part
et elles ne se logent pas que dans les
hôtels et donc il y a quand même des
études qui montrent très clairement dans
les très fortes destinations
touristiques mais pas que les grandes
métropoles y compris des des
destinations touristiques pour leur La
Rochelle
saint-malot évidemment Paris mais aussi
Strasbourg mais aussi Lyon et aussi
quelques joyau comme ça touristique où
il y a pas un seul logement disponible
pas un seul donc si ni à la location ni
à ni à la location ni à l'accession
parce que l'attractivité et l'économie
liée au tourisme et alors cette année
c'est encore plus important que la coupe
de monde de rugby et les Jeux Olympiques
font que si vous êtes propriétaire vous
pouvez vous consacrer uniquement à la de
ces populations et ne plus gérer le tout
venant et ce qui est paradoxal
aujourd'hui y compris dans notre
fiscalité c'est que c'est des phénomènes
qui bougent très vite he donc il y a 7
ou 8 ans c'était déjà un peu différent
là ça s'est accéléré et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui la fiscalité fait que
vous vous vous vous privilégiez plus
quelqu'un qui loue pour un touriste
qu'un propriétaire qui loue à long terme
pour une famille donc vous voyez on a on
a mais c'est des effets de bord très
important qui est aussi lié à la
mondialisation très clairement de la
même manière qu'en effet les jeunes sont
éclatés bien plus qu'avant on voit qu'il
y a des phénomènes de mobilité un peu
folle ce qui me moi m'inquiète beaucoup
dans la période c'est qu'on a on est en
train de gagner des batailles
intéressantes socialement quand même
celle du plein emploi euh le sujet de la
réindustrialisation je le trouve
extrêmement important fondamental y
compris dans des dans des territoires
moi je me suis beaucoup engagé je pense
au bassin minier du pas decalais et du
Nord on va amener des milliers d'emplois
àkererc à lance à Douet où est-ce que
les gens se loge en réalité il y a pas
il y a pas de logement vacant
actuellement dans C territoire et en
particulier dans le logement social qui
est fait l'objet de réhabilitation il y
a pas de logement vacant et ce qui est
très troublant c'est qu'on on nous dit
d'ici un an d'ici 8 mois il y a 1000
personnes qui arrivent là 2000 personnes
qui arrivent là et les collectivités
interrogent tout le monde y compris les
bailleurs est-ce que vous pouvez me
faire des choses en urgence parce que
moi je sais pas accueillir cette
population ni en locatif ni en terrain à
battir des en accession et vous voyez ce
qui ce qui est étonnant dans cette
période c'est que je pense qu'il y a
dans les années 50 60 Michel me
contredira si je dis bêtise mais j'ai
quand même l'impression qu'il y avait un
accompagnement du plein emploi avec
quand même un accompagnement par du
plein logement si je peux parler ainsi
c'était les grands ensembles mais aussi
l'accession sociale à la propriété
notamment pour la classe ouvrière là
aujourd'hui on fait le plein emploi mais
on dit aux gens ton problème de logement
c'est un problème individuel et ça moi
j'y crois pas du tout et c'est pour ça
que je pense que c'est un problème
éminemment politique éminemment régalien
c'est qu'en fait ça oblige ça oblige à
michelantal DUP il y a eu un ministre
qui s'appelait monsieur Claudius petit
qui avait qui avait dit on faisait des
grands ensembles et il a dit attendez
attendez on fait des grands c'est lui
qui a sorti le terme de grands ensembles
parce qu'il a dit il faut introduire des
commerces au sein de cet habitat et faut
introduire de l'emploi et ça a été les
années 65 c'était ça a été pensé comme
ça mais maintenant enfin bon voilà mais
je vais prendre un un exemple qui va la
ville nos villes nos centres ville ont
besoin de trois fonctions essentielles
les
flics la police les instites et le
personnel santé aucun Élog dans V et
bien qui de ces troisl qui peut habiter
Paris aujourd'hui qui peut habiter Paris
qui peut habiter Bordeaux qui peut
habiter Lyon qui peut habiter n hab ilst
donc donc je m'en fiche des flics qui
soient crevés je me fiche des instites
qui dorment sur leur pupitre mais
l'infirmier qui me fait une prise de
sang j'ai ça me plaît pas qu'elle a la
main qui tremble parce qu'elle a mal
dormi qu'elle a fait une heure de
transport permettez-moi quand même de
corriger ce que vous dites oui tu peux
corriger voilà je vais vous dire dans
mon travail de journaliste j'ai
interviewé il y a 30 ans il y
AEL des grands universitaires y compris
des prix Nobel ils habitai dans les
banlieu ils n'habitait pas à Paris ah
bien sûr donc c'est pas un phénomène
nouveau il habita ché du log on ira voir
la maison d'Aragon non mais la la
chireté du logement à Paris à Paris est
en effet et en effet pas pas récente et
par ailleurs ce qui est intéressant
c'est que il y a quand même dans ces
métropoles un combat des collectivité
hein compris euh dans pas que Paris pour
faire revenir ces fonctionnaires
essentiels au cœur de la ville y compris
à quelques pas de votre studio là il y a
eu l'inauguration de l'Î au
Saint-Germain je me suis assez batue
pour que ça fasse du logement social ou
demain ça sera ces fction là mais ce que
dit Michel derrière ça c'est que pendant
le covid on est tous à saluer
collectivement nationalement les
travailleurs qui nous sauvent quand même
qui s'occupent de nous et pour nous nous
quat qui nous connaissons bien la
sociologie de des territoires on sait
que quand on gagne moins de 2000 €
aujourd'hui on n'arrive pas à se loger
dans une métropole merci Monsieur lag
grrue je vais vous donner la parole
après monsieur Damon monsieur lagru de
ce qu'on entend dire c'est que le
logement est en situation de le pivot de
la paupérisation sociale est-ce que vous
diriez vous qui êtes un syndicaliste je
vous réduis pas à cette chose là mais
c'est quand même un observatoire
privilégié la
réindustrialisation échouerait si on
résout pas la question du logement
c'est-àdire je pense queeectivement
elles sont liées elles sont extrêmement
liées cette réindustrialisation tout le
monde le dit c'est absolument essentiel
quand je vous dis tout à l'heure aussi
qu'il y a 150000 emplois menacés
pour le bâtiment c'est c'est tous les
segments du bâtiment qui risquent d'être
touchés et bien pour la
réindustrialisation plus vous ferez en
sorte qu'on qu'on qu'on a de l'emploi
qui revienne qu'on ait des métiers qui
reviennent des des savoir-faire qui
reviennent vous allez faire en sorte
aussi que le log enfin l'un va tirer
l'autre vers le haut en fin de compte y
compris même la partie privée s je vais
vous faire un tout petit commentaire sur
aussi le le Emmanuel co disait jusqu'à
2000 €. moi on se rend compte si vous
voulez aujourd'hui enfin un smicar oui
il a du mal bien sûr mais celui qui a
1800 € il a aussi tout autant de mal et
celui qui en a 2000 parfois pour les
histoires des fait de seuil et de
plafond il a pas d'aide parce que lui
l'aide à la personne il il en bénéficie
pas et puis alors son accès au logement
c'est c'est un véritable parcours du
combattant et puis tout ça fait que le
logement c'est qu quand je vous disais
que l'industrie la réindustrie isation
est lié donc avec le logement la notion
qualitative j'insiste là-dessus la
notion qualitative fait que si demain
vous faites en
sorte que le logement n'alimente pas
l'emploi vous saz quel est le risque
c'est qu'à un moment donné on paye moins
les gens B oui et si on paye moins les
gens on va rajouter de l'inflation parce
que les gens ne consommeront plus et
aujourd'hui c'est quand même pas un
hasard si quand je vous disais puisque
vous parlez de chiffre tout à l'heure je
me suis permis de fier une petite
donnée c'est que la consommation en
elle-même donc si on la met en parallèle
du logement donc industrialisation les
emplois le logement et la consommation
la consommation en 3 mois là elle a
baissé de 11 % sur ce qu'on appelle les
produits manufacturés et donc
l'alimentation fait partie c'est
absolument terrible ça veut dire qu'à un
moment donné tout va être lié et moi je
pense alors je je j'élargis mon rôle de
syndicaliste je me réduis pas
effectivement à ce rôle là
sur la partie
économique si un jour les banques
centrales
décidaient de dire sur les Tau directeur
immobilier on fait ce qu'on appelle du
financement cantonné c'est-à-dire on
créerait un tuyau spécifique pour le
refinancement par que les banques elles
se financent elles achètent l'argent en
ce moment vous savez ce qui se passe
quand il y avait pas d'inflation quand
on était à inflation quasi zéro savez
que les banques ils empruntaient sur les
marchés financiers à la BCE ils
empruntaient Banque centrale européenne
voilà banque centrale européenne merci
ils empruntaient à taux négatif c'estd
que en en réalité pour pouvoir lever des
fonds on leur donnait un bonus ce qui
veut dire que quand il vendait le crédit
à 1 % avec un bonus supplémentaire il
gagnait plus d'argent en marche
qu'aujourd'hui donc il y a quand même un
truc qui va pas monsieur dam vous
vouliez dire quelque chose i je voulais
faire trois commentaires rapides tout
d'abord sur il nous reste peu de temps
vous allez voir ça trois commentaires
très rapides je vrais résumer le gros
sujet de ces métiers que l'on juge
absolument essentiels et qui ne peuvent
plus se payer la ville et il y a une
très belle formule dans les milieux de
l'urbanisme là-dessus c'est ceux qui
font vivre la ville ne peuvent plus se
payer la ville premier commentaire voyez
rapide deuxème commentaire sur les
besoins alors il y a des chiffres un peu
fétichisés le demiillion les
500000 de logements qui serait
nécessaire chaque année à construire ou
à à à rénover je pense que c'est là
qu'il faut avoir une approche un rien
décentralisée parce que les besoins
certes on peut les les additionner pour
avoir une approche nationale mais ils
sont locaux c'est un lieu commun mais
quand on parle d'immobilier vous savez
il y a trois dimensions fondamentales
c'est ils aiment bien le dire ainsi la
localisation la localisation la
localisation et la troème chose c'est
mon dernier commentaire on l' beaucoup
évoqué là c'est la question du lien
entre le logement et l'emploi nous
fêtons les 70 ans de la création du 1 %
logement je pensais à ça lorsque
Emmanuel k évoquait les années 50 ça a
été une invention géniale et c'est vrai
que l'État a piqué dans la caisse
continue assez allègrement à le faire
avec de plus ou moins judicieux argument
et que les partenaires sociaux
localement peuvent savoir ce qui est
nécessaire et pourrait si son un pour
logement ils en avaient davantage la
maîtrise pourrait mieux adapter les
politiques du logement alors écoutez on
arrive à la fin de cette émission
peut-être conclusion politique Emmanuel
Kos Jacques Chirac quand il était
président de la République a proposé
quelque chose qui n'a pas réalisé à
savoir que les biens publics essentiels
le loge l'éducation la santé devrait
sortir des normes du marché vous y
seriez favorable et sous quelle forme je
pense c'est une question notamment pour
les pour les populations les plus
défavor je suis pas certaine que c'est
la sortie du marché qu'il faut mais
plutôt une régulation et et en tout cas
moi c'est ma vision et sur le marché du
logement on régule une partie du secteur
mais pas sa globalité et notamment on ne
régule pas le ce qui est le plus
spéculatif voilà après vous allez
peut-être trouver que que je manque
d'utopie mais je je suis peut-être aussi
un peu trop réaliste je préfèreis
quelque chose qui marche tout de suite
et donc déjà si on régulait y compris le
marché du fonci on a peu parler mais
retourner à des régulations très fortes
et permettra à mon avis de de de
répondre à à
cela parce que on a cette position
française mais qui est partagée dans
d'autres pays européens qui serait qu'en
gros le marché du logement il va se
régler tout seul en fait c'est pas vrai
et c'est pas vrai parce que d'une part
notre marché est mondialisé et qu'en
plus la spéculation immobilière dans sa
globalité n'a jamais été aussi forte
donc voilà moi je je voudrais plutôt une
régulation monsieur Damon juste une
précision par oui ou non pour ponctuer
cette pour ponctuer cette
émission vous l'avez dit vous avez dit
l'état pique dans la caisse alors
d'après la fondation abépierre et
d'autres encore on considère que l'État
engrange plus de recette fiscales lié au
logement 89 milliards que dettes
directes qui sont accorder 40 milliards
la moitié c'est vrai ou c'est faux c'est
tout à fait exa enfin Emmanuel k rép sou
c'est pas 40 milliards c'est 38 ENF on
peut se bagarer sur les chiffres mais
c'est une équation qui me semble
médiatique on peut la poser comme ça
ceci dit les chiffres la réponse est oui
c'est tout à fait exa dans les ordres de
grandeur voilà bah écoutez on va rester
sur ce chiffre je voudrais vous
conseiller une bibliographie évidemment
dans ce domaine la Fondation Abé Pierre
publie chaque année l'état du
mallogement en France donc son rapport
annuel
2023 je voudrais signaler les
publications du ministère de
l'environnement et notamment de son
laboratoire environnemental le PCA
Julien Damon vous avez publié un livre
qui s'appelle la question SDF au PUF
vous restez sur la même
vision sur la question SDF oui ah c'est
une question qui a formidablement évolué
dans le temps qui est aujourd'hui
confronté entre autres choses à un sujet
très important mais très sensible qui
est celui de la la question migratoire
alors je voudrais également signaler les
publications de l'Union sociale pour
l'habitat que vous présidez Emmanuel Kos
nous arrivons à la conclusion de cette
émission il me reste à vous remercier
Madame cosos Messieurs Je vrais
remercier l'équipe d' LCP qui fait un
travail formidable et avant de nous
quitter je voudrais vous laisser avec
cette citation chaque fois que l'on
refuse 1 milliard pour le logement ces
10 milliards que l'on prépare pour les
tribunaux les prisons les asiles de fou
c'est de qui ça ça pourrait être Victor
Hugo Z mais c'est pas Victor pi l'abbé
Pierre voilà voilà mais justement je
disiss je me disais que c'était trop
facile pour que ça soit laav pierre vous
pensiez au misérable ouais
[Musique]
merci